got to have all the original sharks in
one shot promote the show 15 years and
we're still alive how about that
[Music]
yeah
moving different than all the rest cause
I'm about doing a different New Vision
and no regrets man I used to be a victim
repented of all my stress now excuse me
I'm just fitting and getting it off my
chest yeah but leaving one day we are
above and once you get your shot just
don't turn on the ball hard putting my
team
[Music]
baby that's right that's right can't
control it but that's life that's life
yeah let's spend time more than we spend
cash
[Music]
it's all about golf carts that's all
Studio action golf cart here golf cart
there I prefer to walk get some exercise
around here but now after shooting 14
hours I'm dead so I'm taking the golf
cart
[Music]